it's michelle from lap muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and all-around
nerd
and i am a dinosaur in beauty blogger
years
i started my blog in december 2011
and in the last almost 10 years i have
learnt
a lot as i've read way too deeply into
everything so i had the urge to go
through some of my older posts recently
and unsurprisingly i've said quite a few
myths in the past
like the infamous mineral sunscreens
work like umbrellas
probably you take everything i said
before 2015 with a grain of salt
anyway as i was going through some of my
older posts i noticed a whole bunch of
products that i used in the past that i
raved about
that i don't really use in my routine
anymore so i thought it would be
interesting to go through them
if there's a product that you've
completely discarded from your routine
as well
let me know in the comments if you like
sciencey beauty content click the like
the subscribe and the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos
first up we have the neostrata gel plus
this is a 15
alpha hydroxy acid product it's got 15
glycolic acid
it is a chemical exfoliant and i was
really into this in 2012.
this was a really unusual product back
then especially in australia
with this higher concentration of
glycolic acid there were like
three products now it's actually pretty
easy to find a chemical exfoliant
there's been so many launched on the
market
that i've just never had to repurchase
this i still think it's a
really great formula so neostrata was
actually founded by the scientists who
did
a lot of the pioneering research on
alpha hydroxy acids and polyhydroxy
acids as well
but the markers changed a lot since then
and there are so many great chemical
exfoliants that you can buy for
a lot less money and so i don't think
it's really worth it to pay
top dollar for a relatively simple
formula
knees try to have a lot of really other
great products that are quite unique and
i would recommend getting those
over the gel plus the covergirl lash
blast waterproof
so i have trichotillomania and this is
a hair pulling disorder i've never
really talked about this before because
it's something that i've
pretty successfully managed to the point
where it doesn't really interfere with
my life anymore
except in the realm of eyelashes so
basically
trichotillomania is a compulsive hair
pulling disorder it's linked to things
like ocd and anxiety
it's reasonably common about point nine
to four percent of the population get it
at some point in their lives
and it's more common in women it started
for me when i was about nine
when i was stressed or bored i would
just start pulling out
strands of hair from my head it got
pretty bad at one point i had
really thin patches i started getting
really frizzy regrowth
and my mom gave me some really hideous
haircuts to try to hide the regrowth
i started out by pulling out the most
perfect thick hairs i could find
and then i eventually redirected myself
into only pulling out the kinky frizzy
ones which i don't have that many of
and also my eyelashes now when i'm
stressed i'll like search through my
hair and look for like a kinky hair to
pull out
and also my eyes get really itchy and so
i start yanking on loose eyelashes
a lot of the time when my eyes are itchy
it is actually a loose eyelash
and i also wear rigid contact lenses at
night
and if i get a loose eyelash in my eye
at the same time as the rigid contact
lens
it's really really painful so it's
actually not that bad a situation to not
have loose eyelashes for me
but it does mean that i have really
patchy eyelashes for a while in my early
20s i cared a lot about this because
everyone on youtube had really big
eyelashes they were all putting on false
eyelashes i think it's still a bit like
this now
i used latisse to grow eyelashes i got
eyelash extensions once but that was
actually a really bad idea because it
actually gave me better grip
to pull out eyelashes but eventually i
stopped caring and i wear really thick
eyeliner anyway so it doesn't really
seem to make a massive difference
but if you're wondering why i never wear
mascara or false eyelashes
that's why australian natural skincare
so i'm australian and these brands are
really big here they're also really
reasonably priced
you get them a lot in like goodie bags
from retailers
and i buy a lot of rose of oil they all
sell rosehip oil and a lot of the time
when you buy rosehip oil you get a
little sachet
of another one of their products they
also send out pr samples to australian
bloggers and so
between 2011 and 2013 i used a lot of
these products and they worked really
well on my skin
they tend to have essential oils which
isn't great for sensitive skin
but the only brand that i really reacted
to was sukin
but there are two big reasons why i've
drifted away from these products
firstly they have a shorter shelf life
they use lots of natural extracts and
oils and they use
natural ingredients and so they tend to
go a bit funny in texture after a while
i never noticed any mold or anything but
the texture changes were pretty
off-putting
and since i try out lots of different
products for reviews i never really got
through a container
properly the other issue is that these
brands tend to lean into those
fear-mongering clean beauty denigrating
claims things like they're free from
parabens
there's no nasties i've talked about the
issues with clean beauty before
probably most brands on the market at
the moment have
some of these claims but they're all
varying levels of that
i think out of these the worst brand is
probably sukan for these claims
it's a pretty tricky situation and i'm
not really sure how i should be
approaching this so maybe some
of you have some suggestions so like i
said i love rosehip oil i use it a lot
i've been using it a lot recently
because you can probably hear it in my
voice but i'm getting over a cold
and my nose is really chapped and rose
of oil helps a lot with that
most of the rosehip oils in australia
come from these brands that have some
level of clean marketing
and i get these rosehip oils as pr
samples i don't specifically ask for
them but
my mailing address is on some pr
databases
and i sometimes get them as part of a
package from a big retailer
so i have these bottles of rosehip oil
lying around i'm not going to throw them
out and buy
roasted oil from somewhere else because
that's just a massive waste
i want to be honest about what i'm using
on my skin but i also don't want to be
really promoting these brands that use a
lot of clean
in their marketing with paid
collaborations i started a policy of not
doing paid collaborations with brands
that feature clean a lot in their
marketing
and i explain it to the brands when i
talk to them and hopefully they take on
that feedback
but with sharing my routine in my
instagram stories i'm not really sure
where to draw the line
i think most brands now have some level
of these clean claims in their marketing
and sometimes it's really hard to pick
up like you won't necessarily see it on
their instagram sometimes you have to
dig into their blog
and i try a lot of different products
out and it's really quite labor
intensive to spend like two hours
searching through
everything a brand has ever said before
i post like a picture of the six
products i used my routine that day onto
social media
and brands change their marketing all
the time and so it can be really hard to
keep track of that
anyway i realized this is a very
michelle specific problem
and if anyone has any suggestions i'd be
really grateful
lush angels on bare skin i really like
this product
it's like a really nice gentle scrub but
again it's that shelf life issue i could
just never get through a tub of this
before it went off
and so i started freezing little nuggets
of it in my freezer i still have some in
my freezer i'm pretty sure
but it's just a bit of a hassle and so
i've been using skinfoods pineapple
peeling gel instead
as my physical exfoliant that's also
listed in my 2012 favorites so clearly
i'm just
a creature of habit netting sponge on a
stick
this is a really efficient way of
washing your back
and i got this from daiso so it was 2.80
the problem is
netting sponges tend to grow mold if
they don't dry out properly and since
it's all bunched up
it doesn't dry very easily you'll see
all these really scary stories in the
medical literature
about people getting infections from
these infected sponges
and yeah sponges like this they hang up
they have skin cells and beauty products
all over them and they're wet
and so that's like the perfect place for
bacteria to just start
having generations of babies i am
actually quite prone to folliculitis i
get it really easily when my skin's
irritated
and damp and so i get it when i have
laser hair removal for example
my skin's irritated and i put on that
gel afterwards which is meant to cool it
down that makes me break out in little
spots
i get it with period undies because they
tend to be synthetic and they also have
this printed label on the back and that
rubs against my skin
i get it from dance classes when i
swivel on my butt
because again it's that irritation of
friction i even get it when i wear
synthetic clothing and i don't shower
for more than 24 hours which isn't as
gross as it sounds
it's like if i shower in the morning on
one day and i don't shower till the
evening of the next day
then i tend to break out in little bumps
again anyway i have no regular schedule
my life is chaos i have chaos dragon
energy
so i switched to exfoliating towels
instead these towels again you can get
it from daiso i also got one from
innisfree
and because they're one big sheet then
they dry out a lot more easily
plus you can just chuck them in the wash
sesh feet top coat
is that even how you pronounce it i feel
like i haven't had to say it for like
years basically this is this amazing top
coat that smooths out your nail polish
and makes it look like it's just
all one thing there's no like bumps or
anything it's just smooth
and glossy i pretty much just got lazy
and stopped painting my nails as much
and now if i do paint my nails i want
something that lasts for ages
so the way that seche vape works is it
kind of just redissolves everything
and then re-dries it into one smooth
layer but that also means that
everything just gets
chunked up into one giant layer and so
it peels really easily
so now if i paint my nails i want
something that lasts for ages and so
ceshvite is just not a great option for
me
bb cream so bb cream is like meant to be
an all-in-one product
it's got sunscreen and foundation and
skin care all in one
but a lot of the time with all-in-one
products it just
doesn't quite do really well in any of
the domains
it's like a jack of all trades master of
none sort of situation
the big problem with bb cream is that
it's really quite pigmented so it works
well as foundation
but you can't really apply enough of it
for it to work well as sunscreen
so if you're applying sunscreen
underneath it then the skincare benefits
aren't really there either because the
skincare isn't going to have an easy
time getting to your skin
and so it really just works as
foundation and as a foundation
it's not great because most ranges have
like
two shades so now i just tend to use
sunscreen and then foundation on top
or a tinted sunscreen that isn't really
pigmented so i can apply
a lot of it like the right amount for
good protection benefit coralista
this is a blush that's like a really
pretty coral color with a slight shimmer
and it's like a really natural looking
shimmer i actually said it was pigmented
in my review and back in 2012 compared
to other australian blushes
it probably was but yeah there's a lot
better products on the market now and
with this product
i think if you're quite pale then it
works quite well
and i think that's the case with a lot
of benefit products to be honest
a lot of them are designed for pale
people so
i switched to a lot more pigmented
blushes now that have a bigger shade
range
one of my favorites is milani so i hope
that was an interesting trip down memory
lane
do you have products that you've just
completely given up on as well let me
know in the comments
if you liked the video click the like
you can also subscribe to my channel
you can also follow me on instagram at
la muffin beauty science and check out
my blog as well
see you next time for more nerdy beauty
talk